rise of the Tomb Raider unfolds in a
valley haunted by echoes of older times
abandoned structures dot the landscape
while bygone kingdoms lie dormant
beneath the ground even the current
inhabitants long sheltered from the
outside world still hunt and gather as
their ancestors did and for Lara Croft a
person intent on escaping her past this
is not a comforting place but in her
pursuit of supernatural artifacts go he
or she must so begins the next adventure
for the iconic Explorer
in 2013's Tomb Raider reboot developer
Crystal Dynamics thrust Laura into
danger against her will
ruining her on a strange Island with
even stranger secrets in rise of the
Tomb Raider she's running headlong into
the fray at her own pace seeking the key
to eternal life if that premise sounds
trite that's understandable
the Holy Grail grants the same power in
Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade and
Nathan Drake a more apt and recent
counterpart spent uncharted 3 hunting
for the Fountain of Youth
yet rise of the Tomb Raider anchors
Lara's story with its own believable
characters and emotional weight
Lara refuses to acknowledge her father's
death opting instead to seek the divine
source the object that could stave off
death and grief for good Crystal
Dynamics doesn't use magic as a
storytelling crutch though it injects
mystical elements in a way that makes
sense within the world they occupy and
on the other hand as a third-person
adventure game
rise of the Tomb Raider excels rather
than collide gameplay and stories share
the same space supplementing each other
and emerging as a cohesive whole like
its predecessor rise of the Tomb Raider
places you in an expansive world filled
with soldiers of the shady Trinity
organization
this isn't a sandbox game though
subsequent areas are gated by ability
unlocks you gain certain items to reach
new self contains owns in the story but
can also return to older areas with
newfound abilities by navigating three
separate skill trees you can build Lara
however you want as long as it fits your
playstyle the resulting backtracking is
rewarding - it highlights just how much
Lara has improved in the meantime
a Byzantine war girl
there are also more actual tombs this
time around these catacombs are also
well worth your time both are the new
abilities they unlock and the design of
the platforming puzzles inside you alter
water levels operate pulleys and shatter
icy barriers all the while working
toward improvements to Lara's climbing
hunting and fighting skills they're the
kind of puzzles that make you feel smart
as if you somehow forwarded Crystal
Dynamics in the process
codex and in your fight against enemy
soldiers and nature itself you also
gather resources for healing salves and
special ammunition when stranded in the
wilderness with few supplies and little
on her back laura relies on nature for
survival unfortunately this process
becomes tedious after only a short time
it devolves into a constant process of
pressing the same button on identical
trees and bushes and dead rabbits over
and over again rise of the tomb Raider's
world is stunning but I was often too
distracted by the repetitive abundance
of resources on an otherwise beautiful
canvas but gathering is part of the
overall improvement process and it makes
sense in this harsh landscape Lara treks
through and this is where I rise the
Tomb Raider truly shines Crystal
Dynamics erases the barrier between
gameplay and story making an almost
seamless experience in the process
exploration leads to gathering which
leads to crafting which leads to combat
which leads to new locations and
throughout the game cutscenes are
succinct but not without substance
they don't believe her the narrative
monologues and grandiose asides but
still manage to build character and
establish tone there's a surprising
amount of detail here - Lara warms her
hands over fires shiver when the wind
picks up and slides her feet through
taller piles of snow there's enough
exposition here to provide meaningful
context but not enough to get in the way
of well having fun
and when it comes to combat rise of the
Tomb Raider is superb the variety of
options available in any given firefight
is staggering in fact these encounters
often feel more like puzzles I opted for
stealth when I could waiting for a lone
soldier to stray from the pack before
finishing him or sending arrows into
snipers from a distance environmental
objects aided me as well as Lara's
crafting abilities let her fashion
molotovs and cans of shrapnel at a
moment's notice it's just another way
rise of the Tomb Raider paints Lara as a
survivor she's resourceful there are
slight difficulty spikes late in the
game but if you've explored enough and
spent your hard-earned researches on new
tools the fight will be challenging but
not overly so
rise of the tomb Raider's first shot
pans over a vast foreboding landscape
will soon come to know on an intimate
level in many ways this functions as a
promise on the part of Crystal Dynamics
that there are big things ahead of us
and at the end of Lara's journey after
we've seen her through this adventure
and experience everything the world has
to offer it's clear that that promise
was kept